well hey let's bring in the other the  other judges that know this is keeping  you and I'm happy wait to bring them  Emmitt waiting I'm not ready  [Music]  you want to know honestly what I'm doing  fun feeling I don't want to see it you  inspired me Simon that you were able  well here's what it is Terry Crews is  the consummate host good friend and  everything what is he known for besides  hosting our show having huge pants and  able to control them right and you can  do it now till right I can do it now as  well yeah you know when you get one of  these really bad auditions on the show  and all you're thinking is how quickly  can they get you off the stage yes means  it isn't subscribe to my channel  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel please  don't make me keep going